the film opens with the main protagonist
oh Dai seal grasping a man by his tie on
the edge of a building with the man's
life In His Hands daisu says that he
wants to tell a story when the scared
man asks his name the movie transitions
15 years back daisu is completely drunk
and out of his mind he is in the police
station for misbehaving and hitting on
someone else's girlfriend he tries to
pee in the waiting area and the
officials restrain him nonetheless he
continues to cause problems daisu
asserts that he was on his way to his
daughter's fourth birthday he even shows
them a cute bag with wings he bought for
his daughter the officials somewhat
believe in his story but still decide to
lock him behind bars fortunately daisu's
friend zhuan arrives at the scene and
convinces the officials to release him
the two then go to a phone booth after
daisu finishes talking to his daughter
Juan joins the call however when the
latter turns back after ending the call
daisil is nowhere to be seen in the next
scene we learned that daisu has been
kidnapped he is sealed in a hotel room
where his food is delivered through a
trap door most of the time he has given
dumplings which have a peculiar taste
Daisy tries his best to learn about his
captor his intentions where he is or how
long he'll be held but unfortunately he
finds no answers when his hair grows
long he is knocked unconscious and
trimmed captures take his blood sample
and extract his fingerprints too one day
daisu learns from the television that
his wife was murdered and he is the
prime suspect since the police found his
fingerprints in blood at the crime scene
he then realizes that his captors have
framed him as a murderer in the outside
world later daisu is seen hallucinating
and hurting himself he is slowly
starting to go insane as he hasn't
interacted with anyone for months to
keep himself occupied he often writes a
journal about the cruelty shown to him
by his kidnapper as the years pass daisu
watches events on his television such as
the attack on the World Trade Center
changes in the presidency and so on when
not watching TV he spends a good portion
of his time Shadow Boxing promising not
to spare the person behind his misery
after 14 long years he finally manages
to remove a brick from the wall and
decides to get out in a month however
before he can proceed with the plan a
mysterious lady comes to his room and
hypnotizes him when dicey wakes up he
finds himself inside a weird suitcase on
the rooftop of a skyscraper a person is
on the edge of the building about to
commit the unthinkable dicey was
intrigued as it has been years since he
has seen another human nonetheless he
hurriedly stops the man and tells him
the story of his captivity this is the
same scene from the beginning of the
movie after hearing how Dai Seuss ended
up there the guy starts narrating his
own story but our cocky hero leaves
uninterested daisu takes the lift where
he steals a woman's sunglasses he then
decides to test his fighting skills he
teases some thugs deliberately gets into
a fight with them and beats them up
easily with this daisu concludes that
his years of self-training have worked
after a while a stranger approaches him
and gives him a wallet and a phone he
tells Dai soon advance that he doesn't
know anything so asking any questions
might be futile daisu believes him and
goes to a sushi restaurant where he
meets a young Chef Mido as the two are
chatting he abruptly receives a phone
call from his captor the man gives him a
clue as to why he was held captive he
says that daisu might get his answers if
he revisits memories from when he was in
school later daisu faints after
consuming a live octopus Mido helps him
them up and takes him home while he is
asleep she reads his journals and gets
to know everything about him sometime
later dicey regains Consciousness and
looks around the house when he learns
that Mido is in the washroom he
immediately rushes there and tries to
force himself on her but she manages to
defend herself Mido admits that she
likes him but is not ready to be
intimate yet she then patches him up and
helps him track his lost family
eventually they manage to find his
daughter's address it turns out that
after his wife's death his daughter was
adopted by wealthy doctors knowing that
she is safe and has a good life daisu
gives up on trying to contact her he
also promises to visit his wife's grave
only after killing his captor however it
is not going to be an easy task at all
diocese's only clue to solve the mystery
is the dumplings he had for several
years in captivity so he and Mido visit
every restaurant in the city to taste
their dumplings later he finds me though
chatting with someone when dice who
confronts the man he reveals that he
knows about daisu's captivity and even
mocks him for it hearing this daisu now
believes that Mido had been working with
the stranger and suspects her of being
his captor in a fit of rage he leaves
the house telling Mido that he can't
trust her after this daisu continues his
visits to the restaurants and finally
finds the one where the dumplings were
from eager to catch the culprit he
follows a delivery man on foot daisu
then finally reaches the prison where he
was kept he investigates and finds out
that the place is a private prison where
people pay to keep someone captive after
a while daisu locates the prison Warden
Park in the building and tortures him
for answers the latter claims that he
doesn't know anything saying he never
met the client in person however when
daisu brutally pulls out some of his
teeth Park reveals that he has the
recordings of the phone calls with the
client after getting his answers staisu
hands park over to the prison guards
warning them that he has already lost a
lot of blood he then fights off the
guards and defeats them even after being
stabbed multiple times while returning
home dicey collapses on the road because
of his injuries a man who had been
following him all along approaches his
unconscious body and takes him to Mido
shortly after dicey wakes up to see
himself wrapped in bandages and Mido
sleeping near him then he goes through
the audio recordings he received from
Park but they reveal nothing more than
someone asking to hold daisu captive for
talking too much next he locates his
school friend juhuan and makes him
listen to the audio but as expected the
latter doesn't recognize the voice this
devastates daisil as he is now back at
square one however he is still not ready
to give up after brainstorming some
ideas he starts looking for the man Mido
is talking to earlier who knew about his
captivity they learned that his name is
Evergreen and track his Hideout easily
Evergreen turns out to be a rich man who
challenges daisu to find out his captor
and the reason for his captivity within
five days he claims that if daisu wins
he will happily kill himself but if he
fails me doe will be killed he also vows
to kill every woman daisu will love
throughout his life in case he loses the
challenge daisu attempts to torture the
answer out of Evergreen instead of
accepting his
challenge however the tables turn when
Evergreen threatens to commit The
Unthinkable by switching off the
pacemaker of his heart if Evergreen dies
daisu will never find the answers so he
reluctantly accepts the challenge after
the encounter daisugos to mito's house
and sees her being tortured by Park and
his men park is there to take revenge on
daisu for pulling at his teeth he holds
daisu to the ground and is about to pull
out his teeth but right then evergreen's
right hand arrives he has brought a
suitcase full of cash which he presents
to park the latter is very much pleased
by the present so he orders his men to
leave the place as they are walking away
daisu angrily threatens to cut off
Park's hand as revenge in the next scene
we see the couple traveling in a jeep
Mido claims that she is afraid of
getting killed at the hands of Evergreen
but dicey reassures her that she'll be
okay at this moment we get to know that
their entire conversation is being heard
by Evergreen via a tracing bug planted
in daisu's body this way he gets their
real-time location and can listen to
everything they say that night daisu and
Mido are shown being into with each
other as they lie in the bed daisu
sarcastically says that he feels
thankful for his time in prison because
he wouldn't have met me doe otherwise
later Evergreen puts both of them to
sleep by releasing a mysterious gas
inside the room they're in he then comes
into the room and leaves a gift box on
the table when dicey wakes up and checks
the box he shockingly finds Park's hand
inside of it the fact that Evergreen
knew he wanted to cut off Park's hand
and also their current location makes
daisu realize that he has been bugged he
frantically checks his entire body and
finds one in his shoe which he removes
with the help of the technician
following this the couple goes to an
internet cafe to find out more about
Evergreen shockingly they learn that
daisu and Evergreen went to the same
school before daisu got transferred they
also find his real name to be woo Jin
dicey then calls his friend juhuan who
went to the same school as well the
latter reveals that wujin's sister Yoon
jinxyo committed the unthinkable shortly
after daisu's transfer he claims that
she was a I'm not going to say it
who slept with every boy at school Wu
Jin who is listening to their
conversation from the other room is
furious to hear them talk about his late
sister in a fit of rage he goes to the
other room and beats Juan to death woo
Jin then gets on a call with daisil and
blames him for his sister's death after
the call daisu is approached by Park who
wants to work against Wu Jin for cutting
his hand off daisu accepts his offer and
asks him to keep Mido safe until he
returns he then visits one of his old
school mates in a beauty parlor as they
engage in conversation the woman reveals
the jinco committed the unthinkable due
to rumors about her relationship with
her brother in high school daisu then
visits his school and recalls what
happened to day before his transfer he
had seen Wu Jin and his sister making
out in one of the classrooms they
stopped the act after noticing him but
it was too late daisu told this to
joofon and the rumors about the brother
and sister quickly spread throughout the
school back in the present a vengeful
daisoo goes to wujin's Penthouse and
defeats all of his goons he then tells
Wu Jin that he has won the BET since he
has found all the answers he was looking
for dicey remembers wujin sleeping with
his own sister in high school and
accuses him of erasing all his memories
so he wouldn't remember the incident
however Wu Jin denies erasing his memory
claiming the daisu forgot because it
wasn't his business cutting back to the
past we are shown that when daisu left
for transfer news of the brother and
sister's relationship spread like
wildfire the rumors were exaggerated so
much that people began saying that
jinsio is pregnant coincidentally her
period stopped and her belly got swollen
this led her to believe the rumors she
couldn't bear the thought of a baby
growing inside of her that was also her
nephew ultimately this led to her demise
ever since that day woo Jin blames daisu
for spreading the rumor that cost him
his sister's life in the present wujin
shockingly reveals that daisu and Mido
fell in love because he had hypnotized
both of them it turns out that the two
were hypnotized before they first met
and everything was designed in such a
way that they were destined to fall in
love Wu Jin then points to a box and
signals die seal to open it the box
contains some old family pictures of
daisil as he goes through them he sees
his daughter getting older by each
picture then in a shocking turn of
events it is revealed that his daughter
is none other than me though as daisu
tries to process the information wujin
reveals that park has kept me dough
hostage he was always on woojin's side
and the hand was just a trade-off for
some cash a few seconds later Park
phones die seal and hands it over to
Mido she nervously mentions that park
has given her a purple box daisu knows
that the box contains the family
pictures so he desperately warns her not
to open it he then begs Wu to not let me
doe know the truth because she is not at
fault he admits his sins and even cuts
his tongue out as remorse feeling pity
wujin funds Park and orders him to keep
the Box closed he then gets inside an
elevator remembering the last moments
with his sister we see that he tried to
save his sister until the very end back
to the present he commits the
unthinkable having Avenged die seal in
the final scene daisu is with a
hypnotist he is being hypnotized to
forget the truth about his daughter the
movie ends as medo hugs him
affectionately and the father and
daughter live on Happily as a couple
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching